[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to insight Germany
today my guest is from Denmark which is
of course Germany's northern neighbor at
the age of 20 she moved to Hamburg to
study psychology and never really went
home today and milena Henning is a
celebrated psychologist a sexologist a
writer and TV presenter welcome to the
show thank you I have a rather mundane
question to start off the show you came
here by train was it on time it was it
was a Danish one I will find out it's
because it the questionnaire you said
something about trades and punctuality
we will come to that a little bit later
but I want to start at the beginning
like a good psychologist would with your
child no no but I want to because I
thought of Denmark and I think we have
an international audience you think of
Copenhagen and they most probably don't
know that the second city is where you
come from all who's as I said that it's
the second big city yes but everything's
about wonderful wonderful Copenhagen
yeah but oh this is actually a very old
city too and and nice nice buildings and
a lot of culture yeah but it's ute land
it's like actually driving up from
Germany over the border you're in
Denmark the Copenhagen you need a fairy
or Suitland is great even if everybody
think it's flat but in all this was it
great to grow up there
when you live in done my when you grow
up in Denmark and live in Denmark you
don't think big at least not like not
back then because we didn't have
internet or anything so you were just in
your little bubble I would say I think
it changed today it's more fun to grow
up there now I wouldn't want to live
there now because it's too small okay I
need more impulses I want to show a
picture straight away - this is you
like standing out in a crowd I would say
because guess what you're in the yellow
dress yeah that was actually in
Copenhagen because we moved over there
and that was in a big big dancing school
in Copenhagen I won the first prize and
my father his hobby was taking pictures
photos and I have so many pictures at
that time and he laughed picture and
taking pictures of his little like
princess yeah that was before he left
now I'm five or something they're five
yeah but as you said before he left you
split up was that as sort of terrible
time for you as this I think when you
were seven yeah yeah that was waking up
at least that before like as I said in
my bubble and having both parents there
and suddenly he came into the room and
said I need to talk to you and he split
up my brother and me and he told me we
are gonna take a break your mom and I
and that's what do you believe then if
you're seven that this is gonna be a
break but then I didn't see him for five
years and he they really split up and
yeah you didn't see him at all at all at
all yeah because yeah it's it ended up
like that because I think he was ashamed
and my mother tried not to talk bad
about him at home she didn't she said
it's I I'm mad at him but you don't have
to be but it wasn't kind of organized I
didn't see him for four or five years
and you moved around a lot I believe yes
yeah all the time before that we did
because he was a police officer a
criminal criminal one he had to we had
to move around as it as he used it thank
you a detective
and I had to change school all in the
second grade I had three different
schools so I I moved and moved and never
really get got to get friends that's a
problem I think about that but you get
good at other things if you keep you're
dropped into a class and twenty-five
people your age peer group looking at
you and you get to perform or you get
together free yeah I think I wait I got
later on but in the beginning I didn't I
was not strong I was out not being
invited to the party
not feeling well yeah yeah when you went
to aarhus aarhus I must say on on Aversa
t did you get invited to parties then a
bit later on yeah but actually my whole
puberty was more in my own little room
being sad that I was not invited because
I changed school in the sixth grade too
and that is just when it started
happening and I was out so it was much
later it's around 20 where I decided
when I move now I'm gonna be somebody
different I'm gonna be out there and be
trying to be seen I really move to Joe
because you studied law and yeah you
changed the psychology and change to
Germany yeah it's funny because I just
had a this morning in the Train I had a
little talk with with a another traveler
and he was a lawyer
and I we just talked about it's quite
the same isn't it I have a lot of
couples in there and I'm the one trying
to find out the facts and trying to deal
with the situation and help people to
get to understand each other again and I
I started with Lauren
yes and went just for a little trip to
Germany and never came back
and in Germany you cannot use your
Danish 3 years of law and go on and yeah
it's different law you can forget it
yeah didn't forget it
so I just I I think I had a year or
something not knowing what to do just
getting used to the country and then I
got into this modeling stuff and yeah
yeah we've got a picture ready I just
yeah this is a great picture you said
tiles yeah
but this this you did to financial
studies yes exactly because after three
years or something I I realized this is
all so sorry
sometimes little boring being on the
Fasching fair fashion fair sitting
around and somebody said why don't you
study psychology and that was like yeah
right and you know I why I'm just
thinking back in August
when when we have this how do you say to
be
paid for what what do you want to study
before I started the law there were two
possibilities for me psychology and the
law but on that day when these people
were coming to tell us about their
professions the psychology went ill so
he didn't come so I started the law I
often thought about that that it's
sometimes a little peculiar how do you
end up where you end up yeah but it may
be maybe it was better to start a little
bit later something like but that's what
that's how I ended up there yeah I
wonder I just want to nip this in it's
not really because you were saying about
big boring if that but that that's not
naked
was not boring to look at but I get it I
mean did that take a long time to do no
I can make a confession because these
two up there
they're not mine we do things that are
prepared before one then we put them up
yeah so they're not mine it didn't it
didn't take a long time in the show but
moving on this psychology I want to ask
you later
you've had a long career as a
psychologist and I want to ask you later
what your thoughts are about your
insights into the Germans and the and
Germany but do you remember what they
were like
then when you arrived here at 20 do you
remember what you thought I mean it is
your neighbor you know yeah and but I
didn't know Germans we went to the
border from Denmark to buy stuff to buy
alcohol it was expensive in Denmark or
sweets so we just went to the border and
went back I didn't know anything about
the Germans and when I came with 20 I
was yeah sometimes shocked actually I
felt so alone because they were so
unfriendly
back then I started working in a bank
actually one year yeah
and had to go to a lot of be heard and
yeah and public places and it was so not
friendly I was really I thought don't
they like me why are they be treating me
like that I was just age and we'll find
out why later
but you've moved on from psychology to
sexology or maybe it's not really moving
on maybe it's part of the same thing no
it is moving on yeah
here's my part of psychologist was I was
in studying neural psychology it was
about the brain and I worked in a
rehabilitation center for brain damage
it damaged so it's totally something
different and that was again why did I
do
why did I end up here sexologists
because again some friend it was one
sentence kind of when I started thinking
about what can I do now with my
psychology thing and I'm not working as
a model anymore do I wanna sit there can
I take this much longer this brain stuff
and heavy psychology and some person
said to me my best friend back then why
don't you become a sexologist and I had
never thought about that and that is
strange because I've been seeing Danish
broadcasting about psychology they have
a have a famous one in Copenhagen I saw
her so many times on television and when
my friend said that I thought yes that's
what I want to do and I can combine this
and then it is about the brain again
yeah I'm sure we'll find out more in a
minute okay here you are right now
though out and about promoting and
researching your own TV show here in
Germany and we've got two signed copies
of the book to give away it's going to
be available this year in English but
this is the German version of the book
as I've said before it's a great way of
learning the language it's full of
illustrations and photos to help you
just write to us at the usual address
that's in site DW de and you
automatically get entered into the draw
and you could be the lucky winner ever I
have to say a very good book I'm very
impressed having two teenage children
myself oh yeah um but why did you write
the book it's 2014 it's all out there
isn't it mm it could be but no I'm
sitting with grown-ups in my practice
clinic and they don't know
yeah they don't know stuff it's like
there's a lot of pressure and wrong
leavings I'm supposed to do this or that
or every woman can come more
in there and it is know that that's not
how it is and people don't know how it
is
is the internet an enemy yes I know
you're trying to do yeah yes and no
because um you can find a lot there but
it's difficult to sort out what is what
is good what's wrong what could yeah
it's too much perhaps and everybody can
put stuff out there so it's better if
you know more yourself you can decide if
this this is for you or not that's what
we try to explain in the book not to
explain you should do this or that but
get to find your own opinion and think
and feel what you are yeah but do we do
we want everything to be discussed
should everything be out in the open
you know this is I mean I'm talking from
another generation of course yeah I
don't think it should not not everything
should be out in the open but a lot of
people has this idea of this works on on
its own on its own itself and if it
doesn't they have problems and then it's
good if you can discuss it somewhere in
a relaxed normal way I get that a lot
this we shouldn't talk about all this
but there's so many people having
problems when I just I just mentioned
women and orgasms it's 30 percent it's
every third woman out there who can't
orgasm who wants to yeah
so it's about the Germans I think no
this number is actually worldwide and
it's it's the same with men one third of
men it could yeah so it's not orgasms
but other problems and yeah that's a lot
of people and it's sometimes easy to
change things if you know a little more
about your body and if you allow to talk
if you can talk to somebody ask
questions
let's talk though how did the Germans do
I mean I I'm thinking you know this is
as far as tolerance of sexuality is
concerned Germany is you know way I'm
there I would say wait well you're
obviously this looks as though you gonna
disagree with me but we've had we've had
a German Foreign Minister who's gay we
have yeah
current cabinet minister whose there's
been with yeah footballer Thomas hits
let's bear yeah I'm out
being a I mean Germany's way ahead is
nurse yeah I I would alternate around
your the first interview a moderation
person that's not getting nervous
actually yes you are every show yeah and
every really that's a good question if
if it was so normal
why is it then that in every talk show
I'm in I'm warned before not to say
these words and take care of the don't
go there to marginal OSC in Germany in
my German talk shows I'm getting like a
little extra sorry we need to inform you
that this other that person my ones they
don't liked sex about they don't like to
talk so don't talk about sex but you say
oh it's interesting so it you say it's
something I'm not getting nervous but
I'm an Englishman who I mean I think
many people around the world have seen
one example mr. Bean's sketch where he's
trying on the beach he's trying to
change and he's got a towel round him
well when I first came to Germany -
Germany the towels weren't there yeah
you're right but you would never in
Germany find a sketch like that and
where you mean where the towels were not
there that was in in the special parts
of Germany all Germany how do they if
khakha those naked beaches and starfish
yeah but normally that is the thing you
would not find a joke like that if you
go into a sauna in Germany okay people
have no clothes on now they don't I
don't know what go into a sauna in
Britain I haven't lived there for a long
time but you know what I've told the I
would have thought the Brits I can only
talk for them really I'm more prudish I
think everybody is I think it's all over
the world but the Brits joke about it
the Danes joke about it the German don't
Germans don't it is like no we can't
explain it as so difficult it says if no
I think it's all over the world it's the
shame this thing about religion and
don't touch you
self and all that stuff at round like
1900 for it and all these how do you say
sobota forbidden forbidden things and
it's still in our heads because many
they don't joke about it because they're
having a great time that could be a
possibility but I joke about it and they
go red or look the other way so I don't
think it's that oh there is something
about it it's interesting it's difficult
because I would have thought it was a
much prayer Society yeah yeah yeah you
gave me on the telephone I have to admit
sorry you want yeah I was just gonna say
there is this thing about they're worse
actually in the before the 1930 s before
the National Nazis I don't like that
word but like yeah there were tradition
here sexual tradition about yeah reached
doing research and yeah and all that and
it disappeared because many of the the
doctors and people doing that they were
homosexual themselves and it actually
totally disappeared because they went to
America saved their lives and a lot of
books were burned and a lot of research
material were burned and so it it was
lost for Germany so we had to start
although we're late let's say that we
started up again later we talked on the
phone a few days ago I do this with my
guests to have a little chat and one
thing you said to me that interests you
talked there about the Nazis and then
there was the other that divide in
Germany between East and West and you
said to me the East Germans are more
open sexually yeah and if so I I it's so
uncomfortable to talk about because I
don't like putting people in boxes but I
I it tends to be like this in my when I
have a talk with the patient I don't
like to call them patients a client and
if they're like really relaxed and open
they're often from West Germany I was
from East former East Germany so I
started thinking about it and asking
like taxi drivers here in Berlin what is
that and they all come up with answers
going in that direction like it was a it
was
little it was closed in it doesn't cost
anything and there was another view
state view on it you could go to the
pharmacy and get your Angie baby pool
just like that you can get you could get
an abortion there were special books and
they would that it was been taken care
about this sexuality was that you could
talk about it you could learn about it
mhm and and it does something it did
something to their mind and they III saw
a television show about Cuba sex in Cuba
and again somebody said yeah it doesn't
cost any money and it's allowed so I
said I didn't explain it till the end
yet but there is something about that
yeah dad it's Denmark well so slow spin
a little we were the first [ __ ] on
porn country in the world that back then
without internet and stuff yeah I won't
give this there the final answer to that
one solution and I think there's
something about it it's having fun
without beat that being expense yeah you
can have you can have sex and fun yeah
let's have a look back now at the
history of sex education in this country
which whatever my guess thinks has
surely progressed from when I was a kid
[Music]
my guest is an Marlena heading who's a
celebrated sexologist
here in Germany we we both noticed there
a lot of that report had to be pixeled
yeah because we're an international
broadcaster and there's no watershed I
mean there's no nine o'clock in the
evening you know this come this goes out
at various times around world do you
think do you think that's right that it
should be pickled or do you think no
yeah no I don't know I think it's wrong
because this was what is two seconds and
it's breast and you were not like
specially focusing on the breast and
trying to get somebody aroused and stuff
that was what we had with the book we
were nominate it from
government Germany for the human book
price and suddenly had to go there in
another for another thing because
somebody else meant that we were porn we
have to go through the same up Tai Lung
almost to do he had to talk about why we
maybe not your department
why yeah we are not porn now I have it
black on white we are not porn but it
was said it is porn because of the
breasts people what do you think of
today have we made progress generally I
mean or have we created for our children
a different set of problems with
everything being available well I'm
talking about maybe peer pressure yeah
concerning sex yeah with a difference
here pressure perhaps yeah a tricky one
yeah a tricky one I think we have made
progress now we saw color and yeah
they're different people back then who
did very good work that it's possible at
all for me to do what I do something
changed because my television show was
in public a public proper broadcast no
private television so that was a huge
step that it was possible to broadcast
something like that where you see
breasts and yeah we actually showed sex
so something happened but there is quite
a discussion about that though I believe
because it is a public broadcast yeah
you work for and what your opinion is
yeah I've all right imagine excuse me
yes but you obviously think this is a
good thing but do you understand perhaps
the opposite argument do you understand
the people who think this is sorry this
shouldn't be done with taxpayers money
yeah yeah yeah I can't
yeah but again what is it that taxpayers
money or for what is a public station
for to to get out to the to everybody to
think is to show important stuff to do -
how do you say not educate yeah it will
take people so it's very important to
get this out that sex can be loving
normal
and you can learn to have fun and not
just believe that it happens on its own
it doesn't it happens that you get
somebody pregnant you people find out
how to put one thing into another and
that's how it happens but to have fun
with it and enjoy sex and live longer by
the way having good sex your whole life
that is not easy learning and education
a bit it's you're saying it is about
learning a lot of it is yes there so
you're born with a kind of a reflex
arousal
reflex everybody find out fine finds out
about that even in their nap nappies
little children try to have more fun so
that is there but the rest you it's
something you learn and experience and
as I always say it doesn't come in it's
not flown in during puberty here it is
and this experience for younger people I
would say I believe you're writing a
second book called called make more yeah
is that for another generation yeah
that's actually for after if for the
second puberty after hormones change
again mid 40 50 but the interesting
thing is this book is for for teenagers
but parents read it yeah yeah because it
could be that you're they learn a lot I
want to move on to our questionnaire and
I should explain to people because you
might not know what you said no we
actually did this questionnaire of the
phone yes wants to do on the phone so I
tell you what you said that you maybe
you say although I shouldn't have said
that
oh yeah because under cool German I we
right here dead school German in other
words a cool German who's not around
I've written down here you said head
come you said not Freud and the like so
you're not a fan of the great German oh
no no yeah he started at least talking
about sexuality with real people in a
praxis and but there was a lot of things
yeah that were not allowed and he didn't
like masturbation and that's the best
way to get to know your own body when
you start so yeah it's not it's
difficult okay right it's about
conflicts and things you can
yeah yeah another well we get to the
coming two more in my opinion of the
controversial ones ingenious German
inventions you remember what you said to
me yeah I think I think something to eat
huh I hate VW gulfs and now everybody's
oh yeah yes fabulous okay are you know
this they're in shock I'm having a heart
attack there and all the crew in the
studio are you don't like the vite the
Volkswagen God it's like nope yet oh god
I cannot say it it's like yeah boring
okay the car industry on my the best
kept secret in Germany this refers back
to the beginning of our program this is
like in school and I was you said the
trades are punctual and to the Cameron
of cameraman have just fainted I should
[Laughter]
give you a hard time
this is like in school and I blog out
totally what you're saying it's a
fantasy that about punctuality here Oh
punctuality yes of course that is really
do the trick I didn't I didn't get it
acoustically when you just ask no it is
my husband-to-be he's an American and
his biggest problem here's he says it
almost every day
I thought the Germans were perfectionist
I thought the Germans were punctual and
that is actually not the case
I think so they might might might yeah
they're normal people no let's move on
to something nice the best thing about
living in Germany do you remember what
you said that is something to eat isn't
it no oh God yeah that's one good thing
it's a big country because I talked to
my pop too sure about Denmark where my
book comes out next in three weeks and
he said yeah you don't sell many books
in Denmark so in Germany we sold a lot
and that's good because I have something
to say to people and that is really it's
getting out there now they are great
readers actually
yeah about this country yes yes we
should because you've expected so we
should talk about culinary achievement
Ryba : yeah yeah yeah because that is
for a danish person i love it i bakhoum
yes yeah yeah not pretty at pip yeah
that's good yeah and finally finally
I'll let you out of your misery
Oh God yeah you said talking about top
town did everybody writes per lid and
you didn't write by then no you said you
put your favorite German places
Eppendorf and the place your top town is
yeah because it's I think because of all
the water and Little Britches Varia
Dilek and small it's kind of small it's
like words the word village village
thank you that was the word because
Eppendorf means Epping village yeah so
that's your part of Hamburg yeah and
it's just nice it's like a little like
Denmark I'm used to water and I think
Berlin is too big and as the taxi driver
says too many by M stars now baton to
road work oh yeah for 20 years now okay
already let's have a look at some of the
things that make Hamburg such an
attractive place according to our guests
yeah one after the other numerous ships
make their way up the river Elbe to
Germany's largest port for more than 800
years the port has been the heart of the
city it's largely withstood the test of
time you can discover the port's history
on a tour that takes you through
modern-day docks and the historic
warehouse district dispatcher Scott
the red brick buildings were built more
than a century ago on oak pilings and
you can find out more about the area's
past and present in the districts museum
here you get an idea of the mercantile
traditions that dominated the Spicer
stock back then goods from all over the
world were stored here cocoa coffee tea
spices rugs but it ceased being a hub
for cargo transport in the 1960s and the
port relocated to a new container depot
to the west Hamburg has many diverse
neighborhoods each with its own face and
its own culture
santé Kali is a firm favorite of early
birds and night owls they all converge
here at the fish market at the crack of
dawn every Sunday
the name fish market is a little
misleading however of course there's
fish but you can find just about
anything here typical for sanctipauli
are the small obscure shops and
businesses like Harry - Bazaar the
former ship's captain decided to sell
coins but his customers were more
enthralled by his decor and so his shop
became a paradise of maritime
collectables from all over the world
[Music]
the Reeperbahn is sunked Poly's more
glitzy side once the place where sailors
want to have some fun today it's more a
tourist domain here you can find bars
clubs discos theaters and musicals one
of the year's biggest events is the
September reeperbahn festival featuring
three days of music on twenty stages
with local musicians and bands from all
over the world where other cities have a
palace
Hamburg has its City Hall it doesn't oh
its splendour to royalty but rather to
its own hard-working people that's
something that Hamburg residents are
proud of showing off it said that City
Hall has more rooms than Buckingham
Palace
[Music]
right behind the City Hall is the old
Stock Exchange
it's another symbol of the pride of
hamburg's traders founded in 1558 it was
Germany's first Stock Exchange business
was conducted here up until just a few
years ago the merchants also formed a
fleet of convoys ships they would fight
off pirates so the merchants goods would
reach Hamburg safely Hamburg Germany's
maritime city and the adopted home of
our guest today on insight Germany and
Marlena Henning I should actually give
you a chance because I think maybe I was
a little cruel in the questionnaire
you've been here quite a time this is so
what are your favourite pluses about
Germany I think there are some because
it's a big country and I there are so
many possibilities there's a culture
possibilities it's it's I can always I
can get up in the in the night and go to
the cinema some kind of I can go to the
Opera there's a lot of as a mixture of
people from all over the world I love
that it's it's big I need to know that
when I live somewhere and yet you live
at the top of it yeah kind of there's a
bit more beyond happy
yes but it that's what I like it's a big
country and and I do like I think the
Germans are kind of perfectionistic they
they do I'm allowed to be very specific
when I talk about sex and being like
medicine
it's about brains and bodies and stuff
and in Denmark it's more about the doing
of it and having fun here it's allowed
to be like a doctor talking about sex
like me that I like I want to share a
couple more pictures oh yes because this
fascinated me this is actually a drawing
by your partner yeah can you tell us
about it do you recognize me you can see
it's me can't you yeah he's a little too
of you yeah he's an illustrator and he
threw me as some Valkyrie and
says like guardian of love and it's
because he's a big fan of Nordic
mythology the Nordic gods and the
goddess of love is fryer and she had two
cats to draw her chariot and what the
Vikings used to do were they when they
marriage married people gave them cats
as the present as a symbol for the home
to guard you love really and be into in
a loving feeling the cats are everyday
your symbol for that because it's there
leads to my next poem I got myself to
the cats the cats cats
Norwegian Forest cats because my my
partner asked me to marry him this is
the next cat in the picture this is my
ring my engagement ring so we have love
in our house but you'd say so you may
have said this off the cuff in the
makeup room but you did save okay but I
didn't sleep well because my cats were
talking so we are talking family they
are really yeah one of them like you can
talk to her but we don't know what we're
talking about yeah they're talking yeah
they keep you awake yes dear I want to
show one fine pictures I'm not a very
good picture but I want to ask you about
this bit of a singer yeah I took some
lessons and God is taking over the model
yes sing sing yeah and I had made some
moderation too and this was a
combination I was the moderator of a
show and I have to sing one song it's
Michael Jackson's yeah Jack's number
come on give us yes I do
I would have told you but I yeah
actually in fairness you come loving
I don't know but you can't really do
Michael Jackson without a band so I
wouldn't press you well
finally the Danes are meant to be the
happiest people yeah
how did the Germans do oh do you know
the number on the list what number are
they further down but I actually think
it has to do about social security and
stuff feeling safe because then Marcus
they take care of people in another way
so you can actually feel more safe and
then my being an old person or a sick
person but you feel safe here in Germany
had been a very fabulous guest I could
talk to you forever
fact I might ask my producer we should
have part two I think and milena Henning
thanks very much Vittorio's
we've got to go thank you for watching a
jovica next week when I'll have another
great guest on inside Germany bye bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]